Today is Monday.
Monday, string beans,...
...all you hungry children, come and eat it up!
Today is Tuesday.
Tuesday, spaghetti, Monday, string beans,...
...all you hungry children, come and eat it up!
Today is Wednesday.
Wednesday, soup, Tuesday, spaghetti, Monday, string beans,...
...all you hungry children, come and eat it up!
Today is Thursday.
Thursday, roast beef, Wednesday, soup,...
...Tuesday, spaghetti, Monday, string beans,...
...all you hungry children, come and eat it up!
Today is Friday.
Friday, fresh fish, Thursday, roast beef. Wednesday, soup,...
...Tuesday, spaghetti, Monday, string beans,...
...all you hungry children, come and eat it up!
Today is Saturday.
Saturday, chicken, Friday, fresh fish, Thursday, roast beef,...
...Wednesday, soup, Tuesday, spaghetti, Monday, string beans,...
...all you hungry children, come and eat it up!
Today is Sunday.
Sunday, ice cream, Saturday, chicken, Friday, fresh fish, Thursday, roast beef,...
...Wednesday, soup, Tuesday, spaghetti, Monday, string beans,...
...all you hungry children, come and eat it up!
All you hungry children,...
...come and eat it up!